Their Ex?"
The game show where two
contestants compete to prove
they're doing totally fine.
Let's meet our players,
Amy and Julian.
Come on out, guys.
Welcome to the show.
No.
Amy, tell us about your
relationship.
Oh, well, actually Aiden and I
aren't broken up-broken up.
We're just kind of on hiatus
because he made out with
somebody at a party in front of
me, and I totally overreacted.
I tried to apologize,
but it was too late.
I already made things
super weird.
Pathetic.
Julian.
Oh... story's
a little different.
I was about to propose
to Maggie.
Who wouldn't, right?
And then she, uh, decided
to move to San Francisco.
But it's cool.
I have my own things going on,
you know what I mean?
I developed this new
social networking app.
It's called Klooper.
And you'll be hearing
about it.
No, I won't.
Let's play!
Contestants, you will now
receive a phone call
from your ex.
Whoever holds out the longest
without picking up plays first.
He looks like Aiden.
Not even remotely.
(phone vibrating)
Remember, all you have to do
is nothing.
You just have to have
an ounce of dignity.
Hey, are you in town or--
(buzzer)
You fool, it was me.
Is she--
Is she with you?
No, she's not with me,
she's in San Francisco
having the time of her life.
You're with me
in this room.
Amy, you've got control
of the board.
Hit that button
to select your challenge.
"Mutual Friend!"
Okay, Amy,
your challenge is
to have a conversation
with a mutual friend of Aiden's
and not ask about him.
Let's bring out your friend
Melanie.
Hey, Mel.
Hey.
What's up?
Nothing... hung over.
Ugh.
What'd you get into
last night?
Oh, popcorn at home.
You?
Some party in Greenpoint.
Did you go with Kelly or...
Yeah.
Was Aiden there?
(buzzer)
Yeah.
Okay, what was his
vibe like?
Like, did he seem sad or--
Disappointing.
All right, Julian,
you've got control.
Hit that button.
"Change Your Status!"
Okay, Julian, your challenge
is simply to change
your online
relationship status.
Okay, piece of cake.
No problem.
We're just gonna
change that to
"It's Complicated."
(buzzer)
Hear me out.
Nothing complicated about it.
You are alone, Julian.
Amy, hit that button.
"No Excuses!"
All right, Amy,
your challenge is to hear
a piece of information
that could be used as an
excuse to reach out to your ex
and not act on it.
Oh.
Not a problem.
It shouldn't be,
but here we are.
"There was a fire four blocks
and two avenues away
from Aiden's house yesterday."
The thing with this particular
one is that he walks to work
that way sometimes,
so I feel like
I should probably just
step out and call him
and make sure he's okay.
(buzzer)
Actually, you know
he's okay because
he was at that party
in Greenpoint.
You really need to
pull yourself together,
you're embarrassing
yourself on television.
All right, it's time to play
the final round.
Contestants, please step into
the nostalgia chamber.
♪
Your challenge is
to hear the song
"I Can't Make You Love Me"
by Bonnie Raitt
and not cry or eat carrot cake--
are you ready?
Uh, can we do
a different song?
No.
Play the song.
(muffled song playing)
♪
(buzzer)
Julian's crying and eating cake.
Amy, that makes you our winner!
Step on out of there!
Congratulations,
your prize is Aiden.
You win your ex back, Amy.
Oh!
Oh, my God!
Baby, I missed you so much!
(buzzer)
Ooh, sorry, Amy, but that was
your final test.
You're not over your ex.
What?
Tough break.
(mumbling)
Yeah, sorry about that.
Julian, you don't win either.
Nobody wins.
There's no way to win this game.
Well, that's all the time
we have.
Tina, if you're watching,
give me a call anytime.
(bleep) you, I love you--
this is all for you!